it was one of the largest missile
barrages yet to be Unleashed hitting
targets across Ukraine an hour before
dark
this was a residential building in
central Kiev one of two struck not far
from the presidential Administration
I know the strikes disabled our
electrical Grid in many cities of our
country we are working we'll restore
everything we'll get through everything
glory to Ukraine
the Ukrainian government believes more
than 90 missiles were launched at
Targets in 10 regions and up to 12
cities
our air defense took out 70 Rockets but
unfortunately 15 Rockets hit energy
infrastructure as City official after
City official reported explosions it
became clear that not for the first time
Ukraine's ability to produce and
distribute electricity was Under Fire
cities in the north South Center and
West reported partial or total blackouts
the national Energy company described
the situation as critical these attacks
then a sequel to a wave of weakly
strikes in October ahead of what for
many will be a crippling winter well if
the object of this wave of strikes was
to hit critical infrastructure and
further pressurize the National Grid
it's clearly working look at that an
emergency operation taking place at the
site of one of the strikes here in Kiev
with the exception of a spotlight driven
by a gen generator it's taking place in
almost total darkness Petro Roman Chuck
described the moment his building was
hit killing a neighbor he knew well
he saw the flame then explosion happened
glass shattered in smoke-filled
apartments the neighbor we constantly
met her the building was very enably
they say she died
Tuesday's attack comes days after
Russia's humiliating withdrawal from the
southern Port City of Harrison it also
coincides with the G20 meeting in Bali
where leader after leader called for an
end to the war Russia's answer with 7
million ukrainians now said to be
without power is clearly no